Falls with us in the Washington do you
see a Paul welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey Dave Michael sure what's up
so me and my wife are getting a little
worried about our unit long pay off plan
so currently we're looking to get out
debt within the next year to year half
and we all about ninety five thousand
basically we're getting worried that if
we pay it all off and would say
Democratic hopeful like Elizabeth Warren
gets elected in 2020 and we miss out on
the student loan forgiveness bailout it
seems like we would have voiced in a lot
of money but at the same time we're
thinking that this is another empty
promise and we should just continue
paying off our debt so that's basically
the question is if should we just revert
to making the minimum payments and kind
of hope that something like this happens
or should we just continue failing
ourselves out and then push on babysat
three four five well the way you do
critical thinking on a flowchart
is you look at percentage probabilities
and the percentage of probability of the
next thing that percentage probability
the next thing which gets you down to
what the percentage probability the
actual event is so I would start with
you'd have to get Elizabeth Warren
elected percentage probability okay okay
bout is likely right now as nothing
happening not a chance
okay my opinion but people said that
about Trump too and he's the president
so who knew you know it spot anything is
possible in today's climate
who knew but she's a fringe player all
the way we on the left and those of us
out here in the fruited plain not a
chance
okay but I mean she could get elected it
could happen there could be enough
extreme left east to put her in there
it's possible she's brilliant I've
gotten to do some things with her over
the years and I really think a lot of
her as a person by the way just as an
aside I'm not just trashing her but I
don't agree with her very often but
she's very very smart and very very
articulate so she's gonna be a fun
person to be having the election cycle
for sure because she's quick and she's
tough
so I it'll be fun anyway aside from that
once she gets elected she does not get
to decide
about student loan forgiveness as the
president you realized that no it's
known as an act of Congress and you know
around places like Tennessee when we say
something so difficult it's not going to
happen we go well that's like an act of
Congress you know what I'm saying you
ever heard that phrase used that way
like it's very difficult to seldom
happen so let's say percentage of her
getting elected times percentage of them
actually passing this while you're still
alive pay off your student loans dude
don't wait on them to fix your life
you're gonna be dead does that make any
sense yeah I thought we thought it over
and we were like all right you know what
we're just gonna continue doing it
because the chances of Hollis being
elected or somebody else well and
getting it through Congress exactly
right if it gets to Congress yeah we're
like all right work is gonna pile up a
bunch of interest let's just knock it
out and then and as true as discomfort
being president doesn't mean you can get
stuff through Congress exactly that's
right just looking at Pelosi and she's
going I mean the stuff he can get done
is just gum denied so it's a process the
checks and balances in our governmental
system pretty much grinds progress to a
halt
Carly Fiorina is doing some decent
discussion of this by the way is that
people spend more time in Washington not
you but the politicians spend more time
in Washington trying to get reelected
than they do actually getting things
done consequently almost nothing
actually gets done so I really I'm
pretty cynical can you tell I would not
wait on them I would fix your own life
that's what I would do